the last couple of years oh there's no
question they need middleton and bledsoe
to get going
i mean if you think about boston with
tatum kimball walker jalen brown if you
think about
toronto with van vleet lowry and siacom
you know you can't do it with one guy
you need these guys going
and i like it middleton playing well
being aggressive they need
all of this from him middleton ten
points four of eight from the field 48
coughs it up williams ahead of the field
to matthews matthews left open fires
and buries it everything working for the
bucks
well the bucks defense is the impetus
for all of this and the magics offense
are getting them in trouble
you've got to be more efficient at this
end take care of the ball get good shots
get back and get your defense set that's
how you give yourself a chance to stay
in this game
[Applause]
mid-range jumper short eight straight
points for milwaukee and now look out at
the other end of the floor
oh marvin williams and eddie's have to
be separated and eddie's i believe threw
a punch
and if he did he's gone
wow this is two guys that you rarely see
in something like this you know there's
guys you expect
i didn't see what precipitated this but
these are not two guys you would expect
to be in this
we'll have to go back to take a look at
where this developed
but a wild sequence
james anders and marvin williams bottom
of your picture
fighting for the rebound you saw
williams take the shove and then step
in and that was what got under ennis
skin
and right there stan we'll see how the
officials deem that
was he flailing his arms to create space
and get williams off of him or was that
a punch
i don't think it was a punch i think
that darvin ham
getting in there ended up slipping more
than anything
you know one rule of thumb is never guys
we have a double file
to determine if there's a potential
hostile act
all right so you heard the officials at
the table they will take an extensive
look at this here
as they look for a hostile act you know
me as a coach
i think i would think if i'm steve
clifford that what giannis is doing
today
to me is a hostile act coming out and
playing like this i consider that
hostile spiro i'm with you coach you
know it's a different definition
i know it might not be in the rulebook
but i would like to be able to
challenge as a coach and say i think
he's being hostile
toward my aspirations of winning this
game
i've never quite thought out of it under
those terms but
i'm with you look at marvin williams
drawing at ennis
annis of course who has had such a crazy
route coach to get to this point playing
with his seventh nba team
steve clifford has really enjoyed
coaching him all the grit
the strength that he has brought to this
club you actually coached him a little
bit in detroit
i love james ennis great competitor
great person
totally about the team
will sacrifice will play whatever role
every time one of these fights happen
you always have to pay attention to the
benches do any players leave the
vicinity it looked like the coaches did
a terrific job you see buttonholes are
not even looking at the freight he's
looking back at his bench players to
make sure everyone
stayed put absolutely i mean that's
something
that i think everyone in the nba has has
learned it's something that every
coaching staff talks about
and your first reaction as a coach all
the time is to turn around and make sure
your players stay on the bench quite
honestly
a little easier in this situation here
in the bubble the way they have the
benches set up
some of those guys would really have to
make a fairly lengthy
trek to get around the barrier and
everything and get out on the floor that
probably helped a little
i didn't see anybody come off the
benches i don't think we'll have a
problem there
i think the issue is going to be whether
or not james innis stays in the game
and whether or not they call that a
punch or if he's just trying to free his
arm up as they're grabbing him
which is what i think he was trying to
do he's certainly not trying to get his
fist up anywhere near marvin williams's
head
i hope he does not get tossed out of the
game
i hate it in playoff games we saw it
porzingis get ejected on a second
technical the other night
unless it's absolutely blatant or brutal
it's playoff time let's keep these guys
on the floor
you saw williams had the the fist full
of enes's jersey
and that's what led ennis
to flail his arms there to get him off
of him
there's marvin williams of course
long-time nba veteran his season began
in charlotte
upon review instant replay has
determined that the double files were
correctly judged
as well we'll have double technical
fouls and we will be ejecting
both marvin williams as well as yes
at james yep got it as it james enos
okay
thank you guys are you good johnny where
we have we have a double files that's
personal file no team files
and then we have double technical files
both players will be ejected we're not
shooting in free throws we're putting
the ball right in bounds
5 39 and 22 on the shot clock we're good
milwaukee's ball
yep all right let's bring in jason
phillips vp of replay operations jason
take us through this
[Music]
both players
all right jason phillips from the replay
command center
so another starter lost for steve
clifford marvin williams
keep peace off the bench for milwaukee
stan what do you think
well i mean this disproportionately
hurts the magic i mean we've already
talked about
their top three forwards are out all for
rue camino jonathan isaac
and aaron gordon and now innis has been
great defensively in this series is out
steve clifford just is out of options
here